on poursuit en compagnie de denise
bombardier hauteur de ouf chez albin
michel bonsoir bonsoir québécoise donc
sans accent
non non jamais alors moi non merci non
je sois là dit jah est énorme on dit oui
parce que je veux que vous m'écoutez
pour ce que j'ai à dire la façon dont je
lui dis alors êtes-vous gothique non pas
du tout je suis baroque moi je suis dans
la musique baroque alors vous voyez que
je suis un peu plus et puis en plus que
je fais tout ce qui tourne autour des
pompes funèbres ça m'intéresse pas alors
patrice pourquoi ouf pourquoi ouf parce
que alors d'abord c'est un roman un peu
l'habitude de céder 10 secondes au
radier c'est plutôt des essais
d'habitude ou 2 kg il ya quelques
quelques romans
owens est plutôt connue comme essayiste
alors c'est l'histoire de jeanne
jade que sa maman avait appelé jeanne
d'arc au début parce que
prénommé jean dénommé jeanne d'arc parce
que sa mère n'aimait pas les angry
heureux préféré rester vierge
et alors elle a laissé tomber la
particule au bout d'un moment après il a
eu à woodstock d'une aumône wittstock
elle a eu sa première aventure amoureuse
mais n'a pas joué
parce que son amant ne savait pas si le
dit d'ailleurs il y aurait si elle est
technique tories dieng ou vaginale vous
rappelle quelque chose et alors
donc
il est venu trop vite
et
est donc il est venu un peu vite pour
qu'elles sachent en réalité si elle
était l'une de l'autre bon et puis donc
elle va sa ville va se marier quand même
et puis elle a deux enfants et elle se
sépare
et aux faux c'est l'histoire d'une femme
de 50 ans séparée avec deux enfants à
charge contre m il vivait avec elle
et qu'est ce qu'est ce que devient une
femme de 50 ans seul est ce qu'elle est
ce qu'elle peut encore et mais est-ce
qu'elle va encore aimer comment comment
comment va se passer ses relations avec
les hommes qu'elle va rencontrer est-ce
qu'il faut que cherche le grand amour ou
pas est-ce que ce qu'elle peut dire je
t'aime ce que quand on lui dit je t'aime
celui fait plaisir ou sami frey 1 mais
c'est surtout un livre drôle c'est que
de toute façon s'il n'y a pas su s'il
était vaginale du clitoris est ce parce
qu'ils étaient américains après la
rencontre est un québécois francophone
et celui là il ya tout quand il y avait
tout compris davance alors là c'est là
qu'elle a connus comme comme l'élu a de
la puissance quoi et puis et puis ça
s'est poursuivi mais c'est vrai que
c'est au fond c'est toutes ces femmes
qui ont 50 ans dans le livre cette année
des personnages ses 30 ans ces femmes là
sont trop ce sont des femmes autonomes
sont des femmes qui kick saab ce qu'elle
veut ce que ce qu'elles veulent dans la
vie sauf qu'avec les hommes et savent
plus trop bien ce qu'elles veulent parce
que parce que je trouve que les hommes
sont pas à la hauteur et puis parce
qu'elle s'amuse entrée à entre elles
enfin en tout bien tout honneur
évidemment mais de toutes les façons
parce que c'est vieillir on n'y échappe
pas eh bien il faut qu'une fois en rire
si tous donc elle se marre qu est-ce qu
on dev-yhu d'ailleurs à 50 ans
aujourd'hui
avait justement
c'est une protection des gens qui ne
veulent pas vieillir c'est cela qu'ils
ont qui sont pitoyables mais pour le
reste on n'a pas le choix alors donc on
prend le bateau et puis on fait avec ces
mots font c'est ça tu as raison
est-ce que derrière ce roman un peu la
bride jones un peu vingt ans après est
ce qu'il ya pas une critique de la
révolution sexuelle du féminisme de tous
ces combats qui ont été aussi les vôtres
n'ont pas dissipé c'est pas une critique
c'est un constat par les femmes arrivées
est se retrouve tout seul et se disent
'mais qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'on a
fait et puis et puis son mari s'est tiré
avec une une thérapie non une thérapeute
qui est spécialisée dans les les
essentielles savait pas que son mari en
était une
mais mais non c'est parce que elle
constate autour d'elle que vous êtes
tous ses amis sont un peu seul et puis
en plus le problème des femmes de 50 ans
c'est qu'elles ont eu un comportement
très moderne dans leur vie courant dans
leur vie et sociales mais elles ont une
dispute de sentimentalité du dix
neuvième siècle sont complètement
niaiseuse alors là bas
elles sont complètement les usa et puis
elle attendait attendait d'ailleurs et
savent pas ce qu'ils attendent mais
elles attendent et el bey l'attend pas
tellement elle a des amis absolument
qu'ils veulent la mac est d'ailleurs
salué la mac et pc le salon bat
d'ailleurs
mais quoi alors c'est cette idée que les
sommes maintenant au tour de 50 ans
partent avec des filles de 20 ou 30 ans
à l'époque où le divorce était moins
pratique et ça n'arrivait pas est ce que
finalement c'est regrettable parce qu'il
vaut mieux un homme qui reste avec vous
qui subvient à vos besoins et à ceux de
vos enfants jusqu'à la fin de vos jours
et de séjour
ils passent tous se pose une question
moi j'ai choisi de rester et du mois
c'est pas ma vie moi j'ai plutôt fait
venir j'étais j'ai même été
pourvoyeuse un certain moment donc c'est
vraiment pas ma vie à moi
pourvoyeuse de quoi celle inverse de ce
que faisait les zones traditionnellement
c'est à dire
payer une pension alimentaire
si on fait mine et se fait pourvoyeuse
ça fait pas pourvoyeur
mais ceci dit non parce qu'il n'y a rien
de pire que de vives offert le pire
c'est l'ennui et moi je crois que s'il
ya beaucoup de femmes qui passent
maintenant les femmes partout si non pas
seulement parce que d'une carte de
résident qui peuvent partir mais parce
qu'elle s'ennuie avec les hommes et
c'est vrai que arrivé à la cinquantaine
en général enfin si je regarde autour de
moi ici comme à montréal où comme à new
york
c'est fin c'est vrai que les femmes ont
l'air de le dire la musique dans l'un
d'entre eux mieux qu'à 30 ans oui je le
trouve moins dur que les filles de 30
ans je les trouve mieux s ont pu dégager
d'un certain nombre de choses et puis
alors que les hommes vers la fin de la
cinquantaine maty 18 c'est à dire qu'ils
se couchent un soir ils s'aiment le
matin le lendemain matin ils décident
qu'ils sont vieux et à partir du moment
où un homme décide qu'il est vieux dans
sa tête on sait ce qui se passe
si bien que dalle si bien que dans ce
livre il ya je croyais des personnages
qui dit ben j'ai passé ma vie à me
promener avec des pilule
anticonceptionnelle dans mon sac à main
est bien là maintenant et rencontre des
hommes qui sont enfin que qui sont vos
questions ben laisser les femmes avec
les pilules bleues dont bon nombre de
pilules
et que pensez vous de cette tendance des
femmes de 50 ans et plus qui sont avec
les jeunes de 25
dans
les fameux
choc et oui et j'ai fait une émission à
la radio ici il n'ya pas longtemps et on
m'a dit une dame qui appelait elle a dit
qu'elle avait le nom de 40 ans de moins
qu'elle dans sa vie mais je pense
qu'elle avait au moins c'est bien ou pas
il fallait qu'elle avait pardon bon bah
si c'est le plaisir mais manger jusqu'à
4 en 1 sd note de best vous savez
j'aurais l'impression vraiment hâte
d'être dans ces trous la proximité avec
son avec son propre livre moi
personnellement mais enfin les femmes
qui sont avec des hommes qui gèle moi
j'ai eu beaucoup d'amis effectivement
autour de moi qui sont avec d un petit
jeune bon ben ça fait plaisir aux âmes
et pier richer rythme mais elles sont
maintenant des veaux d'état
s'est démocratisée
[Musique]
tout à fait parce que c'est accepter
jugement moral sur ceux là dessus tout à
fait quand même encore des gamins les
gars m'a pas mal mais comment vous
expliquez que c'était bien beaucoup
d'ailleurs fait qu'une femme ya quarante
ans de plus que moi
alors je crois
que c'est avec des femmes de 50 c'est
parce que les filles de 30 ans sont trop
durs avec ali fred
sessa choix alors maintenant vous
expliquer que ces phénomènes ne
dépendent pas du tout fondées société
dans les clovisses et y'a que c'est vrai
au québec mais c'est vrai en france
c'est comme ça spectacle universel c'est
ce qu'on appelle la mondialisation
est marrante non il ya de médiatisation
c'est tout à fait
moi je parle je suis toujours c'est le
sida ont tiré dans les pays où ils
étaient en demande occidentale qui est
plus ou moins mais c'est vrai alors tant
qu on vous tient veuf et la dernière un
bouquin qui s'appelait donc lettre
ouverte aux français qui se prennent
pour le nombril du monde alors comment
vous analyser ce qui s'est passé en
france c'est derrière trois semaines
le danger le pen de chiffrage que ça
déprimant pour t'ouvrir et pied en plus
je regarde le deuxième tour 19% pour
l'extrême droite et puis 19 % des gens
qui n'ont pas voté ça veut dire qu'il ya
38 % ya presque 40 % des français qui
sont dans une situation politique que je
trouve moi périlleuse et en plus c'est
qu'au premier tour il y avait le choix
vous pouvez voter pour les chasseurs ils
pouvaient voter pour les fumeurs de
joints il y avait vraiment le soir ils y
sont allés à l'extrême droite et ça je
trouve que c'est pas évidemment c'est
pas la france qui s'est pas la france
qui m'a attiré c'est pas c'est pas la
france pour laquelle je reviens ici ça
c'est ce et au québec
n'ont que la température et on n'a pas
de y'a pas d'extrême gauche y'a pas
d'extrême droite ça n'existe pas et ce
surtout pas institutionnaliser il ya
bien des gens dans leur salon qui vous
disent des choses sur les juifs sur les
noirs sont les geeks mais il ya toujours
des indépendantistes
qui est au pouvoir oui il gouverne au
québec
m'enfin ça n'a rien à voir avec la
gauche la droite
et enfin je suis très heureuse qu'on
n'est pas là je trouve que là on était
exemplaire franchement vous me direz
vous n'avez pas été colonisateurs vous
me voyez de colonies c'est vrai on n'a
pas été impérialistes on n'a pas
peut-être pas une chance d'être
impérialiste mais il reste une chose
l'histoire non mais si ça mais de toute
façon ils pourraient venir on a des
immigrants quand même ne compense pas
les on pense pas ouvrir les frontières
pour les jeter dehors
et puis nous les marginalité je vais
vous dire on est beaucoup plus tolérants
je crois que parce que nous même on est
une sorte de marginalité en amérique du
nord et je crois que ça nous donne une
sensibilité qui fait qu'on comprend les
minoritaires et qu'on contrôle et
marginalité
au niveau fédéral au canada n'y a pas
non plus d'extrême droite il ya un parti
dans l'ouest du canada qui était imparti
mais ce serait ça n'a pas de commune
mesure avec avec le parti de avec le pen
c'est un parti ultra-conservateur ils
sont contre l'avortement ils sont en
action pour le rétablissement de la
peine de mort et tout ce que les
migrants on en prend trop mais enfin il
ya personne qui tient les basses-cours
que vous connaissez
il ya des solutions pour salut inapte à
l'audience
lisons pas l'audience qu'il a c'est à
dire ils sont au pouvoir de décision des
représentants à ottawa je veux dire ils
sont ils sont actuellement parlement
mais ils tiennent pas ce ne sont pas les
solutions que vous proposez ici peu
voyante à vancouver avec des réactions
vos shows très dur
on cherchait peut-être
il ya des ours
grizzly d'ailleurs tous
d'ailleurs votre crise lui voue le
problème c'est qu'il a été candidat au
deuxième tour vous avez été surprise et
moi que nous rien ne vaut une erreur de
la france
mais je vais vous dire que quand je lis
eu quand on m'a téléphoné c'était deux
heures d'après midi pour moi le premier
tour j'ai eu carrément je vous le jure
sur la tête de mon fils la chair de
poule je me suis dit c'est pas possible
mais après coup je suis oui c'est aussi
parce qu'il ya une tradition une
tradition chez vous votre histoire
nous a même vous amène à sommes enfin
c'est réel c'est pas la façon de se
mettre sur la carte du monde sas
ce que la duran duran parce que là la
france intéresse le reste du monde
depuis le premier tour des élections
on verra pour la suite on a un peu honte
d'un coup d'un bon là bas cela dit non
mais peut-être qu'il n'a pas au canada
mais un à un au lendemain c'est
parce qu aux etats unis ils viennent
passer des mails et institutionnalisés
il est impensable que le fascisme se
retrouve en balance comme président des
états unis s'est pas institutionnaliser
donc c'est pas une excuse
est-ce que les extrêmes sont pas dans le
parti république et les fonds et rémi
sella 3
l'illusion que bush il
s'est départi énorme qui englobe
justement ce que ce qui ici pourrait
pourrait fournir des extrêmes c'est les
gens comme goldwater tout ça c'était
contre les sabres bah
oui
c'est ça exactement et quand ça arrive
au niveau national dans le parti eh ben
ils se font ils se font me dire mais
modérée et temporiser part par une sorte
de coup bien bas merci beaucoup dont je
rappelle le titre votre livre denise
bombardier ouf roman chez albin michel
merci beaucoup les corrections de ne
rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
il m'était impossible ou